[Music]
before we start this video i just want
to briefly mention that only 21 of you
are subscribed so if you enjoy the
content please consider subscribing to
help support the channel hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory in today's video we're
going to be discussing minerva
mcgonagall more specifically i'm going
to be discussing aspects of mcgonagall's
character that people who have only seen
the films won't know that's right if
you're a book reader you probably know
all of these at least i hope so but if
you've only watched harry potter on the
silver screen you're in for a shock
number one her jewel with voldemort
there are lots of epic jewels in the
harry potter story the graveyard the
ministry atrium the battle of hogwarts
but as it turns out there were some
micro battles that never got screen time
most of the battles we witnessed in
theaters were between either voldemort
and harry or voldemort and dumbledore
mcgonagall a powerful witch in her own
right only really gets one jewel in the
films and that's the brief one against
snape however with that said mcgonagall
played a very large role in the battle
of hogwarts and without her who knows
what could have happened after molly
weasley kills bellatrix or strange
voldemort erupts and starts going crazy
challenging everyone in his path it's
during this battle that none other than
mcgonagall faces off against the dark
lord with a little help from slughorn
and shacklebolt that is
2. she screams at cornelius fudge
throughout the films minerva mcgonagall
exudes a kind of stern confidence she's
a powerful witch a strong proponent of
the educational system and for the most
part she's in control of her emotions
though she loses it on a few occasions
throughout the story there is one moment
in particular that comes to mind when i
think of angry mcgonagall and that's the
time she blew up on fudge at the end of
the goblet of fire when barty crouch
junior is revealed as an imposter fudge
goes against dumbledore's wishes and
allows the dementors to enter hogwarts
and kiss barty crouch jr though barty
crouch jr was to some deserving of this
punishment allowing dementors to kiss a
criminal is certainly morally
questionable after party crutch jr is
kissed she screams more than harry has
ever seen her before and doesn't relent
harry hears her exchange with fudge from
his bed in the hospital wing 3. she was
attacked by ministry of magic auras on
wednesday the 17th of june 1996 umbridge
and a team of five ministry auras
including john daulish set out of the
castle to arrest hagrid when they
arrived at hagrid's hut hagrid didn't go
quietly and actually put up quite a
battle with dulish pleading for hagrid
to be reasonable as his stunning spells
bounced off of the giant eventually
mcgonagall gets involved how dare you
how dare you it's mcgonagall leave him
alone alone i say on what grounds are
you attacking him he's done nothing
nothing to warrant such at this stage
mcgonagall is shot in the chest with
four simultaneous stunning spells
immobilizing her and subsequently
sending her to the hospital wing at st
mungo's for treatment four her
relationship with umbridge during
umbridge's reign of terror many sat idly
by or even embraced her tyrannical
regime dink filch however some certainly
did not take her abuse in the slightest
mcconnell was a perfect example of this
when harry has a career meeting with
mcgonagall in order of the phoenix
umbridge interrupts time and time again
explaining that harry won't satisfy the
requirement to become an aura with his
current defense against the dark arts
performance to this mcgonagall fires
back that harry's received high marks in
all defense against stark arts tests set
by a competent professor boom five she
screams when harry dies mcconnell is a
tough lady she really is and her
strength of character comes from well a
pretty hard life maybe her life wasn't
hard in every aspect but if you look at
her string of relationships and how they
ended it's pretty tragic so it's no
wonder she can manage a lot however in
her deathly hallows when she sees hagrid
carrying the lifeless body of harry she
falls into complete despair and lets out
a spine chilling scream that echoes
throughout the walls of hogwarts the
scream was the more terrible because he
had never expected or dreamed that
professor mcgonagall could make such a
sound 6. the massive chess set in the
philosopher's stone harry and the trio
are faced with all sorts of challenges
on their way to prevent voldemort from
acquiring nicholas famel's powerful
artifact obstacle number five was the
giant chess set a magical obstruction
put in place that required checkmating
the enemy king to further advance to the
challenges the trio advanced through
this challenge because of ron but it did
divide the group which was perhaps the
intention of this challenge separating
people from any aid they may have had
thus far it's later revealed that it was
none other than mcgonagall who brought
the chess set to life most likely via
the spell pier totem locomotive which we
see her also used later on to enchant
the hogwarts statues seven she didn't
approve of civil trollony if you had to
think of two professors that are total
opposites i wouldn't be surprised if you
landed on sybil trolloni and minerva
mcgonagall trelawny who teaches
divination represents spirituality and
other less tangible ideologies
mcgonagall on the other hand holds logic
and reason in a very high regard a
no-nonsense sort of woman with that said
it shouldn't be surprising for you to
hear that mcgonagall didn't approve of
trulorney even though trelawny always
ended up being right but that's another
video when mcgonagall learns of harry
dying as a result of the grim she's
quick to point out that troloni is full
of it and that he has absolutely nothing
to worry about she even jokes that she
would let harry off of homework if he
dies
eight relationship with neville
mcgonagall is harder than the students
of hogwarts she's a tough cookie but
that certainly doesn't mean that she
doesn't care her relationship with
neville is a particularly interesting
one as especially as a young boy neville
was exceedingly sensitive mcgonagall
gives neville some tough love on more
than one occasion in the books the most
dramatic example being when she severely
punished him for leaving the password to
the gryffindor tower lying around for
this mistake neville got detention and
was banned from hogsmeade visits for the
rest of the year however mcgonagall was
also highly protective of neville saying
the following in response to neville's
grandmother's comments on his choice of
newts remarking that it's high time his
grandmother learned to be proud of the
grandson she's got rather than the one
she thinks she ought to have 9. amicus
carro spat at her in the deathly hallows
after snape becomes the new hogwarts
head master some new morally corrupt
members of staff are hired in the form
of alecto and amicus caro at a certain
point things begin kicking off in the
hogwarts castle and africa sees his
sister electo unconscious on the floor
this prompts him to begin blaming the
students for the attack to which
mcgonagall stands up and protests to
this amicus spits directly in
mcgonagall's face this is the one
instance in which harry completely
enraged was able to successfully use the
cruciatus curse on someone a true
testament to harry's level of rage 10.
she comforted molly and arthur weasley
in the chamber of secrets ginny's life
is immortal danger she's had a run-in
with tom riddle and his diary and things
aren't looking good which causes panic
at weasley household fortunately for
ginny she is eventually saved however
being saved aside ginny went through
something quite traumatic and it took
her a bit of time to resume normal life
mcgonagall went out of her way to
comfort both molly and arthur weasley
during that difficult time revealing a
softer side of the hardened mcgonagall
she also explained to them that lord
voldemort had forced ginny into opening
the chamber against her will and that's
it for this video if you enjoy the
content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember
differences of habit and language are
nothing at all if our aims are identical
the hearts are open
[Music]
you